- What's up, Believe Nations?
Greetings from Copenhagen, Denmark.
My name is Evan, my one word is believe
and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves.
And, my hope is that a little
bit of that rubs off onto you
so you can create something
amazing in this world.
So, to help you on your journey,
today we're going to look
at five lessons in life that
people often learn too late,
and hopefully you can
pick it up a lot sooner.
Lesson number one is don't
sleepwalk through life.
- I advise students, as much
as possible, look for the job
that you would take, if
you didn't need a job.
I mean, don't sleepwalk through life,
and don't says it's all
going to be great, you know,
I'll do this and I'll do that, you know,
I'm just marking time for it to be older.
I've told people, that's
like saving up sex
for your old age.
It just is not,
it is not a good idea.
(laughing and clapping)
- What are you urging them to do?
- I'll explain just
what I'm talking about.
You really want to be
doing, what you love doing.
And, you can't necessarily
find it on your first job.
But, don't give up before you find it.
- Lesson number two,
live life without fear.
- If there was one concept
that I would suggest to people
to take a daily
confrontation with, is fear.
The problem with fear, is that it lies.
Right, so, fear tells you, hey, you know,
if you say that to that girl,
she's going to know she has you.
You know.
And she'll never really
be attracted to you,
if she knows how much
you attracted to her.
(laughing)
Don't say that, no, how we get her
is when she walks by, ignore her.
(laughing)
- This little puppet on your shoulder.
Fear tells you dumb like that, right?
You know, so,
for me, the daily confrontation with fear
has become a real practice for me
since about three years ago,
I went skydiving in Dubai.
Skydiving is a really interesting
confront with fear, right?
I got to stand up, I got to
stand up, I got to stand up.
So, all your friends,
what happens is go out,
how you, oh sorry, I dropped my thing.
So what happens is, you
go out the night before,
and you take a drink with your friends,
and somebody says, yeah, we
should go skydiving tomorrow.
(laughing)
And you go, yeah, we'll
go skydiving tomorrow.
Yeah, yeah, and you go yeah,
and everybody goes yeah, right?
And you go home, you by
yourself, you like, hmm.
(laughing)
You like, well, yeah, I
mean, they was drunk, too.
(laughing)
- Right, so, maybe, maybe
they not, we don't have to go,
we don't have to do it.
So then, that night,
you're laying in your bed,
and you just keep, (startles),
(laughing)
and you're terrified, you keep
imaginin' over and over again
jumping out of an airplane,
and you can't figure out
why you would do that, right?
And, you're laying there, you
have the worst night's sleep
of your life, but you still
have the hope that your friends
were drunk, right?
(laughing)
So, you wake up the next day,
and you go, you know, down,
and you said where you were going to meet,
and everybody's there.
And you're like, aw, um, all
right, all right, cool, cool,
cool, cool, cool, cool, right?
So, you get in the van, and you
don't know that your friends
had the same night that you
had, 'cause they're pretending
like they didn't, they're like, yeah man,
my uncle's a Navy Seal, and
you know, this is going to be
great, I been looking forward to this.
And, you like, oh my God, oh my God.
And your stomach is terrible,
you can't eat, and everything
but you don't want to be the only punk,
who doesn't jump out of this airplane.
So, you get there, and then
you have this safety brief,
and you're standing there
and the guys are telling you
well, if the chute doesn't
open, what's going to happen
is you do--well why the
hell, what could happen,
(laughing)
that the chute wouldn't open, right?
So you do a thing, and what
you do is your first jump,
you're attached to a guy, who, you know,
he's going to walk you out.
So, you go, and you get
there and there's an airplane
and nobody's stopping.
Everybody's still going.
So, you get onto the airplane,
and you're sitting there,
and, you know, it's extra
because you're sitting
on some dude's lap, some stranger.
(laughing)
You sitting on his lap,
and it's like, you know,
you trying to make small talk, yeah man,
(laughing)
So, the deal, you be jumping
with people all the time, huh?
(laughing)
Right, you know,
so, and then you just want
to make sure, you got kids,
you know, you got people
you need to see, right?
You just want to make
sure he's serious, right?
You get in there, so everything is normal,
so you fly, you go up,
you go up, you go up,
you go up to 14,000 feet, and
you notice there's a light,
it's red and it's yellow and green, right?
So, right now, the light's red.
So, then you start thinking, at some point
the light's going to go
green, but you don't know
what's going to happen, right?
And you wait and it goes yellow,
and the light goes green,
and somebody opens the door,
and in that moment, you
realize you've never been
in a frickin' airplane with the door open.
(laughing)
Right, terror, oh sorry, I'm spittin',
(spitting)
oh, sorry, terror, terror,
terror, terror, terror, right?
So, you go, and then, you know,
if you were smart, you sat in the back
so you don't go first, right?
And then people start
going out of the airplane.
And you go, and the guy walks
you up to the end of the thing
and you're standing, and
you're toes are on the edge,
and you're looking out, down, to death.
(laughing)
And they say, on three.
And they say one, two,
and he pushes you on two,
because people grab on three, right?
(laughing)
And you go, (inhaling),
and you fall out of the airplane,
and in one second, you realize
that it's the most blissful
experience of your life,
you're flying, right?
It doesn't feel like
falling, right, it's like,
you actually are kind of held
a little bit, by the wind.
And then you start, you start
falling, you're falling,
there's zero fear.
You realize that the
point of maximum danger
is the point of minimum fear.
It's bliss, it's bliss.
And you're flying,
(nervous laughing) right,
and you're doing it, and
then, 20 seconds, 25 seconds,
40 seconds, and you have enough
time to just kind of be like,
aw, that's that building
I saw right there,
oh, you can see the ocean.
(laughing)
Right, you start doing all of that
and the lesson for me was,
why were you scared in
your bed the night before?
Why did you, what do
you need that fear for?
Just don't go.
Why are you scared in your
bed, 16 hours before you jump?
Why are you scared in the car?
Why could you not enjoy breakfast?
What did you need that,
the fear is,
fear of what?
You're nowhere even near the airplane.
Everything up to the stepping out,
there's actually no reason to be scared.
It only just ruins your day.
You don't have to jump.
And then, in that moment, all of a sudden,
when you should be terrified,
is the most blissful
experience of your life.
And, God placed the best things in life,
on the other side of terror,
on the other side of your maximum fear
are all of the best things in life.
- Lesson number three, stop complaining.
- What if I told you this
is the last Monday morning
of your life?
What if I told you, you die this week?
Would you complain about your crap job,
or that test you don't want to take?
I doubt it.
You would go much higher level thinking.
Well, that's really what it takes.
It takes understanding
that if you're not pumped,
right now, if you're begrudging
what you're about to do,
if you're not looking forward to it.
Look, I respect practicality.
You got to go through school
'cause your parents want to,
you got to pay your rent, you
got student loans, I get it.
But please recognize the
world we're living in.
We're living in a world where
there's so much more
opportunity, this internet thing
created way more opportunity
for all of us. Way more.
I mean look, you might not even be alive,
like, you're Mom and Dad could
have had sex, like three minutes
later and you wouldn't even exist.
And you're complaining.
You could have ended
up being a bus, a tree.
I just don't get the mentality
of being head down sad,
on a Monday morning.
I'm going to make Monday morning my.
I'm going to make you
Saturday, Monday morning.
That's what I want to do every morning,
and that's what I want from you.
Please, take a step back
and think about how awesome
it actually is.
And then, recognize that
you can attack the world,
in a totally different way,
'cause you were lucky enough
to be born during this era.
- Lesson number four,
know your destination.
- Imagine we're standing
in a big empty room, right?
And, we're standing in
one corner, and I give you
a simple instruction.
I want you to go to that corner,
in a straight line, right?
Off you go, no big deal, right?
Without telling you, I slip
a chair in front of you.
What do you do?
You go around the chair.
Now, you just disobeyed
what I told you to do,
I told you to go to that
corner straight line.
But this is the amazing
things about human beings,
which is when we're given
a clear destination,
we use our own creativity and
our own sense of innovation
and our own problem solving abilities
to overcome obstacles to
get to the destination.
In other words, the
destination is more important
than the route, right?
We are flexible about the route.
We are obsessed with
the destination, reset.
We're standing in the corner
together and I give you
a simple instruction,
go somewhere in this room
in a straight line.
And you say to me, well
where do you want me to go?
I'm like I dunno, you're
smart, figure it out.
Go in a straight line.
And so you pick a point
and you start walking,
and without telling you I
put a chair in front of you.
And what do you do?
You come to a grinding halt.
I say, what'd you stop for?
Well, you put a chair in front of me.
Or, you'll make a sudden turn
and go in another direction.
And this is the problem,
it's the same obstacle.
The difference is when you
have a clear destination,
the obstacles become easy to overcome,
when you don't have a clear destination,
you keep coming to a grinding halt
and what we do in our companies,
is we're counting the steps
we're taking along the route,
but we're never looking
at the destination, right?
So a company says, made
million dollars this year,
we we're only planning on making $800,000.
It's like, we took ten
steps, we were only planning
on taking eight.
Where you going?
No clue, right?
(laughing)
We count the steps.
And, so the point is, is
that people want to feel
that the effort they're exerting
actually are moving somewhere.
And so, successful measurement,
successful recognition.
It's not just for the steps you take.
It's not just for the
effort, it's that the effort
you exerted moved us closer to
where we're trying to get to.
And that get to should
be some crazy ideal.
My ideal is to live in a world
in which the vast majority
of people wake up every single morning,
you know, inspired to go to work
and fulfilled by the work that they do.
And the couple of measurements that I use
are if the book is
selling, and, by the way,
people ask me how many have
you sold, I have no clue,
I have never asked the
publisher because I don't care.
I really don't care how many I've sold.
What I care about is the
Amazon rankings and that those
are going steady, or
up, and not plummeting,
because that means other
people, because I don't
have a publicist, I don't
have a marketing strategy
on purpose.
I didn't hire one of those
companies to sell the book for me
and the reason is, is
because I'm not interested
in book sales.
I'm interested in the
spreading of an idea.
So I just use that as a
metric to help me understand
am I sort of marching in the,
because the more I preach,
is it resonating, you know?
And so you have a couple of
these imperfect measurements
that help you understand,
are you going along the way.
So it's not just great effort,
look what you achieved,
because that's what
we're doing now, right?
Our goal is to increase top line revenues
by 50 million dollars.
For what reason, right?
Which is, we have to know the destination,
and then we say amazing,
you took us that much closer,
and if we go to the right,
it's because we were
overcoming an obstacle.
If we hadn't gone to the right,
we would have been stuck forever.
Thank you, you know, it's
not always straight lines.
It's not always straight lines,
but it's in one direction.
She's pulling the cane out.
- And lesson number five, enjoy life.
- I'm not sure about that in
the future, I think I would
dictate I would be stupid,
that's why I should retire early
when I'm young.
That is why I have a lot of
things that I dream I want to do,
I want to do philanthropy,
I want to be a teacher,
I want to go back to school,
I want to do the environment.
The world is so wonderful,
why should we sea of
Ali Baba all the time?
I'm coming to this world, not to work,
I want to come to this
world to enjoy my life.
I don't want to die in my office,
I want to die on the beaches.
(laughing)
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to learn, what did
you learn from this video?
What was your favorite lesson?
Leave it down in the comments below.
Is there a lesson six or seven
that you want to add to the list?
Put it down in the comments.
I'm looking forward to hearing from you.
Thank you again for watching.
Greetings again from Copenhagen, Denmark.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.